the man the man not being the leader
anymore why if he just lacks motivation
what if he lacks teaching you better or
better okay so how okay tell me like
what motivation is to give me an example
um for example okay cool
um I'm like oh babe I want to set up a
cake shop
um just you know to better us you can
manage it but um I want you to like help
set up a cake shop he's probably not
gonna motivate you or push you in the
direction of you can simply getting the
stuff out of the cake Cutters or tools
that you would need I'll give you I'll
give you an example with this cake shop
you know men are more logical so most
men would probably say that's a stupid
idea